now the mother of richard okorage has
said she is confused and devastated
and just wants answers the 19 year old
student who had sickle cell disease
went missing after leaving his family
home in west london on the 22nd of march
he was last seen on cctv in lauten in
essex in the early hours of last tuesday
walking towards epping forest also in
essex
where his body was found in a pond on
monday his mother
evidence joelle has told sky news of her
shock and pain
my heart feels as if it was
if he has been ripped apart
i am completely hollowed and
devastated and empty
he can't just something happened there
richard
is is too far for richard to walk into
that darkness
and learn
is is is it no
you can't it's just it's tedious
it's it's darkness so how did it get
there what happened we
don't know i don't know i can't we don't
know
but i feel something happened there
the forest on his own is it's massive
it's scary it's a place that one won't
wish to go at night
and
it was not a very comfortable place to
be really when i
i wouldn't want to be there but
i don't know it's just
it's a total darkness